The Joe Rogan experience,
I don't need you to be my friend
Ross Broccoli was as comedians.
Great Name.
Yeah.
He's just really.
Look this up.
If you can rub the getaway carrot
top and make a salad shelf dot.
Is there another vegetable guy?
Mm,
I.
Well,
they call me.
They accidentally,
uh,
at the faneuil hall comedy connection.
A black woman called the club and she say,
who on the show tonight?
She was from.
She was from the 18 hundreds.
And uh,
and they said,
well,
it's Anthony Clark,
Jackie Flynn and Greg Fitzsimmons.
And a lady goes,
is Grapefruit Simmons the headliner?
That's a great call me grapefruits.
And is to this day all the comics
of Boston coming grapefruit.
Grapefruit Simmons
should've changed my name.
Right?
That's a great name.
Like,
like emo Philips.
I know that's not his real name.
It doesn't offend me.
Carrot top.
That's on his real name.
Either Grapefruit Simmons.
Right.
But look up Ross,
Broccoli and a and chicken truck.
Maybe you could go out from
here on out as grape simmons.
Grapefruit Simmons,
the artist formerly known
as Greg Fitzsimmons.
I need something for
people to talk about it.
That's the kind of shit.
That's brilliant marketing.
If you're into that kind of thing,
just change your name every
15 years and have people,
you know,
I have to get the twitter account,
change everything.
Grapefruit,
cinnamon.
Greg and I started out probably
within like a week of each other.
Yeah,
right.
Yup.
Back in Boston,
the old Boston stitches
a comedy community,
you know,
and a dude,
we,
you and I have done
gone through the bucket.
We went to some crazy
gigs in the beginning.
Man.
We went through together.
We went through like the
darkest time for standups.
Well,
the early days.
Yeah,
we went through our personal dark.
It stays at the lightest time in comedy,
you know,
I mean we were,
I see young comics today
and my heartbreaks because
they got to scrounge up
stage time.
You and I,
you know,
I would say what less than
a year into doing standup,
we were driving out and
making 50 bucks cash five,
six nights a week.
It was,
for me,
it was exactly one year.
I first got paid by normal of foe
to open up for Warren Mcdonald.
He can garden,
I don't know where it was with some bar.
I was on a like an apple box,
like literally like standing
on an apple box doing comedy.
You can't fucking move
and had a good time.
And then the next time I lurked for
Lenny Clarke does a two times in a row.
I got super lucky.
Normally fall like gotten me here.
You shot up you motherfucker man.
It was like all of us were like,
there was this ascension.
You would go,
you'd wait in line to
get a spot on on comedy.
Hell open mic night stitches,
comedy club.
George Mcdonald,
welcome to comedy.
Hell where the jokes always die.
That Cavita is this whole thing.
And,
and we ran out of booze.
Comedy Hell where you can fly,
fly as high as the lights on Broadway or
crash and burn and the fiery pit known
only as comedy.
Hell.
And that was step one.
And then you.
And then you would get like a guest spot
on a real show and then you would start
to get these like,
you know,
25 to $50 Mc spots where you were driving
the headline or somewhere and you jump
past all that shit because they would
send you out to feature and the headliners
couldn't follow you because you
were out of your fucking mind.
I mean,
you were nuts.
And uh,
and so they had to headline you.
So you started working like
the d rooms but headlining.
Um,
so you started to get an
hour together super fast.
Yeah.
I had to sink or swim.
Those times when the regular would make
agreements to steal each other's shit.
We were bombing.
Say,
dude,
you got my whole act pick up there.
Feel free to just had.
He would come back to that
blow job jokes killed.
If you go back to people that you might
want to wait another three humble,
let,
let the heat die out of that joke.
It was fun for us because we knew we.
Neither one of us should.
There was a point in time where both of
us were doing like middling gigs and we
really didn't have the time.
We really didn't have
a real solid half hour.
So it's sometimes you just,
when you,
when you're a young comic and you
slip in the beginning of your set,
like the odds of you pulling
yourself out of the firearm.
Oh yeah.
I remember one time I was having a good
set and I knocked over a drink and I
didn't address it.
There was,
it was turned on me.
They smell blood.
They knew I was scared.
They knew I was.
I was killing it.
Now
there it's all about their
uncomfort and you denied.
I remember being on this was probably the
cruelest thing anybody ever did to me.
What else on stage?
It was like,
you know,
half filled room back.
It was always like the back of a Chinese
restaurant where they had a banquet
room that they just put a microphone up
and call it a comedy night and I'm up
there tanking it and I'm not
acknowledging that I'm tanking it.
And during one of the silences
that should've had laughed,
rented after one of my jokes,
I heard this middle aged woman
whispered to her husband,
I could hear a whisper and she just goes,
they'll pull best.
Oh,
worse than any heckle.
Oh
Geez.
It would be real hard when
we'd watch each other.
You know,
your watch a friend eat
dick in the beginning too,
because you know how devastating you know,
there's some times where you know,
this guy is not going to pull himself
out of this and he has 15 more minutes to
go
watch them,
slosh through it up there.
Is there a way out of it?
Do you.
What do you have to do?
Like,
do you just have to stop?
Or did he just materials?
That's where we come in.
That's where we'd steal a great job.
I knew that they were grenades that I had
in my waistband that were jealous that
they would just take the
fucking top off and lob it.
And you're back in the game.
Yeah.
It's like we would help each other.
There was a time where I was headlining
where I no fucking business headline and
there was no way.
I barely had 40 minutes and they were
letting me headline these rooms and I
would have to stretch it all out and
if something went wrong it went wrong.
Hard.
That's there's no better motivation to
creating new material than when you just.
Those shows happen and you just
fucking have to get to a work.
Like you need more weapons.
Man.
You went on a weapons too quick,
you're up there dying.
Well,
especially like you can do
the hour when it's going well,
you can take that one bit
and you can stretch it out,
add shit to it.
You're,
you're,
you're doing improvisational jazz and
that our fills out when they're not
laughing,
all of a sudden it's like concentrate.
Everything shrinks down and
now what you had as 35 minutes,
he just ripped through and
17 and now you're scared.
So you're tense and then you got
nowhere to go except the crowd.
So you start fucking with a craft.
They don't like you.
Now did that.
They ended.
They don't like you.
You're not making them comfortable,
so there's not like a nice
flow of energy and so yeah,
the early can feel it.
And the thing about Boston is,
and I think it was kind
of unique to a lot of,
uh,
common other companies,
cities is it,
it is a punchline town.
It's Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
You know,
they don't want to see something esoteric.
They don't want to see a storyteller.
They want you to grab them and just
smack them around and then walk off stage
with your hands in the air.
Well,
there,
there were guys that were doing
it that we're so good at the best.
We came up with an error where,
you know,
I've talked about this 100 times on
the podcast and people always go,
yeah,
yeah.
We know.
They were really good comedians back then.
I don't think people
even understand what a,
what a.
It was like a utopia.
Boston was like this
standup comedy utopia.
There was one point in time,
there was five clubs
in a tiny little area,
seven nights a week club.
I,
there was just that one
block of warranty warranty.
It was nick's comedy stop and then there
was duck soup and there was a common
connection and then Mike,
Mike Clark had the comedy club and the
Charles playhouse above the company.
And then on the weekends you
cut over to Dick dirties,
comedy vault,
50 yards away,
craziness.
And then you get in your car.
He drove down the stitches on common APP.
It's like Holy Shit.
And the best part really was,
um,
and those were for short sets.
You doing five,
seven minutes with a big clubs.
Those were the big ones.
But then you and I would get,
and this is the thing
people don't get today,
is that we would get it for a year.
We get either you get my car,
I get in yours.
We draft providence one night for a 15,
20 minute set for free all the time.
Then we go to Hartford one night,
then we'd go to worcester one night,
then we go to Maine one
night we would go anywhere.
They'd give especially a longer set.
And then,
you know,
we were lucky enough to come up in a
time where the word comedy in front of a
place drew a crowd.
You didn't need to have a big name.
They just were comedy crazy and we just
happened to be dropped in the middle of
it in a city that was a closed system.
They didn't have headliners
come in from out of town.
So the local,
there were four or five big
local headliners that drew
and the and the and the
club's otherwise only booked based on.
Do you crush?
Are you funny?
Are you original?
So it was a meritocracy.
Yeah.
And no one ever thought they
were going to get famous.
What career?
If someone used the word career,
people would have looked at them confused.
Like,
what are you talking about?
All anyone wanted to do was
become a big Boston comic.
It's like the fame that you wanted was
just the being accepted amongst your
peers and having crowds coming to see you.
That's it.
That's what everybody expect to see you,
I think wasn't until later.
I think for us it was just,
I can't.
It's like,
you know when your first fucking a girl
and you can't believe she's letting you
fuck her after jerking off
for three straight years.
That's what it was like when
I was doing standup in Boston.
They're allowing me these stages that
I've watched since I was a teenager in all
this.
I'm on it and they're letting me talk.
That was it.
That's all I needed.
You know,
one of the first guys I ever saw
do a live set was tom cotter.
Tom Cod is one of the first guys.
He's a buddy from Boston is a great
guy and he was in like some sort of a.
The first time I ever went on some sort
of an open mic night and he was like the
first guy that ever went on stage.
I remember that.
I swear to God,
same thing.
He was like a not,
he had started maybe
two years ahead of us.
That guy,
he always used to bum me out
and the reason we used to
bum me out because he was
so fucking funny to hang out with,
but he wanted to take it down
a notch and he wanted to like,
oh,
maybe,
maybe I shouldn't go so dirty.
Maybe I should.
And you wanted to go do.
That's you.
When you're at your best,
you're a pervert.
They twist the crazy twisted.
He is one of the most twisted
dudes and I don't want to.
I'd rather have him on.
We should have him on and do it
together because his stories,
the shit that he would do,
I,
I can't,
I can't say it on the air,
what I can say anything on the air,
but the Shit Tom cotter did,
it was what the first guys I know that
would walk around with his balls hanging
out of his pants.
One of the first guys like no one
was doing that back when we were 20.
We were like 21 or
whatever the hell we were.
And Tom Clark was walking around with
his balls hanging out with his parents
were like,
Jesus Christmas
party and all the comics are there and
he and he would have the hands on his
hips still.
It wasn't like he was hiding.
Oh No.
And I remember at one point we were at
somebody's house and there was a dog.
It was a oliver's dog and it was a,
he had rescued one of those grey hounds.
I think Tom was putting a dill pickle
up its ass in the middle of the party.
Like we were both beyond children.
We were like fucking really
good collection of bad kid.
It was the part of the fun of
having a guy like Tom cotter too,
is because you knew that he
would do something like that.
You knew he would want up things.
You knew if there was a bunch
of comics hanging around,
Carter would find a way to
make something fucked up.
But I always felt like he kind
of pulled back on stage though,
you know.
Well,
he,
yeah,
he um,
in terms of practical jokes and
like guys like Kevin Knox May,
he rest in peace was one of those guys
just so fucking funny offstage and so me
cotter and Nazi or working at a place in
Maine called the laughing lobster which
started to slow business and suddenly
burnt down in the middle of a wet summer.
And so we're up there and we're staying.
There's a condo complex that we're staying
in which was pretty upscale and they
got a pool and I was always hot fucking
chicks from Montreal to come down to
that part of Maine.
So we go,
we're going to go down to the pool
and I don't have my bathing suit.
And they're like,
fuck it,
you've got boxer shorts.
She was wearing boxer shorts down.
So they head down and I
walked down to the pool.
I opened the gate and I walk in and it's
packed and there on the far end of the
pool and I make it about halfway down
the pool and they both stand up and start
screaming.
Greg,
what are you doing in your underwear?
The whole fuck
red faced the
set me up the whole,
well,
what's the pot laws?
Are you allowed to smoke pot street?
Can you spoke here in your studio?
Allegedly,
this is what's going on with pot.
Pot is decriminalized and with
decriminalized does not mean legal.
So in California it's
decriminalized in Colorado.
It's legal.
In Colorado you can just smoke weed,
but they were trying to institute
a law in Colorado where they would.
They would bring out these sensors
and they would have these things.
They attach their nose,
they look preposterous.
It looked like something from a Dr Seuss
book come to life and it's this thing
that literally goes over your nose and
looks like a bullhorn and they would
sniff through it and if they could
detect x parts per million of marijuana
outside of your residence,
they could go and arrest.
You were fine.
Right?
I heard about that.
They,
everybody was.
Everybody was so negative against it
that I'm pretty sure that they dropped it
because people are so angry.
Like how stupid.
That was.
Very 19,
84.
Not only that
gives people the ability to stand outside.
You know what it is,
it's people that were for the longest
time enforcing a policy that's not,
it's not valid anymore.
There's the things that
guys knows that Shit's real.
A
type asshole.
He's already frowning mean well,
that guy needs,
we'd more than anybody
put a smile on his face.
Which silly bitch.
But um,
yeah,
I was just in Colorado and I didn't get
a chance to read a couple of the comics
I talked to.
One of them isn't even doing comedy
much because he's doing pot tours.
So in everybody's doing
now for money in Colorado,
they just do comedy of pop shops.
No,
no.
The Pot tour tours.
People come into Colorado
today when you drive around.
I don't think that they
can technically buy it.
I think you need a Colorado
license to buy it in the shops,
but you can walk through the shop
and smell it and then buy it for you.
And then they go out and smoke it and
it's like a whole tour and they make.
They're making fucking tons of money.
Wow,
that's interesting.
So they,
they probably have material that
they do just for the pot tours.
Oh,
I'm sure there.
Yeah.
They probably have a bunch of corny jokes,
but they said it's great for the economy.
Pay everybody's making money.
Oh,
it's unbelievable for the economy and
that's what that fat fuck from New Jersey.
That dummy,
that governor Chris Christie,
that fucking silly cunt.
He was like,
it'll never be there on my watch.
Yeah.
And he cites some unbelievably
unscientific study that
came out of some major
university,
which is foundation.
I don't know what the study was,
but it was about
abnormalities and marijuana.
The abnormalities in the brain.
What does that mean?
Well,
here's what it means.
What's normal?
Okay.
It just because something has a certain
content in it or your mind reacts a
certain way without a drug,
with the idea that the,
that it changing,
being bad,
you would have to demonstrate that there's
something wrong with the people that
it's changing.
Like what do you.
What are you demonstrating that shows
that this abnormality is in any way
detrimental?
What are you showing?
Like where are all these
people are smoking pot.
That of becoming shaking messes were
all these people that are smoking pot.
Millions upon millions upon millions of
people are smoking pot on a daily basis.
Why is everybody,
are they falling apart?
Is everyone losing their job?
But they forgetting how to drive?
Are they looking at their phone going,
what the fuck is this?
You know,
this is not happening.
Like you're not demonstrating
any negative effects.
You're saying the studies
shows a negative effect.
No,
it doesn't.
Study shows a chain.
She can commission a study
to say anything you want.
Well,
when you look at the word,
the language in that study,
it's not scientific at all.
The language is creepy because the
language says in one of the quotes,
I'm paraphrasing,
it was something along the lines of people
that think that smoking pot even on a
casual basis is,
is fine.
This study is showing
that it's not good at all.
Like you can't say not good
at all because you're not.
You're not demonstrating not good.
What you're demonstrating is a change.
Guess what else changes your personality,
your creativity,
your compassion sex,
your sensitivity to sexual intercourse,
you the way food tastes in your mouth,
your way,
you view other people,
bull,
you're going down.
There's a lot of things going on.
These and these are the same people that
will disagree with 98 percent of the
scientists around the world
who say there's climate
change that are hard studies
with real numbers that are scientific.
Well,
this Chris Christie guys,
fat as fuck,
which is one of the worst things you
could be as a person if you want to be
healthy,
shows a lack of character.
It does.
It shows a lack of willpower.
It shows a lack of focus,
goodson,
determination.
You look what do you,
how do you view life and you're
going around in a sloppy meat wagon.
That's what you are.
You're,
you're not an athlete.
You're not someone who,
if you had a choice between being a person
who respects their body and treats it
well,
or being a person that treats their
body like a fucking big Mac dumpster,
what's your choice?
What you went with big Mac dumpster?
Well,
guess what,
you don't get to lead
because you're not a leader.
You don't get to decide what's
healthy when you're walking around.
Like literally represented.
We going to have a heart attack.
Know,
I think there was a
study that showed that,
uh,
people wouldn't vote for him because
they'd be afraid that he would die in
office,
have a harvest.
He could die of sleep apnea for sure.
He has sleep apnea.
When you were that fat,
you have sleep apnea.
Yeah,
he probably snores.
Like how?
I don't know if he sleeps
the seat CPAP machine.
If he doesn't,
he should.
There's a lot of shit going on.
That guy's proud.
They got on diapers,
a seat pack machine.
He's got a big Mac.
Next pets.
Well there's a diaper
that they're selling now.
Tony told me,
Tara Gousha froze.
A lot of times a menu you could
get a little drippage is a tampon.
The were at the front of your diaper
because you're decleor and they're trying
to sell it as like a normal thing.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
it's this guy with this swollen,
inflamed gut filled with undigested food
and feces that hasn't been pushed out
yet.
Fat that permeates all the different
layers of his skin and yeah,
she's not a muscle left under there.
Then the muscles are all gone.
I'm going to throw you my broken
Thai in my because Lincoln,
trust me.
Just wear a tampon and keep leading them.
Fucking meatball subs.
Meatball meatballs balls inside.
They got Monica got they got.
They got the peppers they put
on the top 10 like my mother.
God bless her.
She died of a heart attack at 51.
He's the guy driving the truck
that beeped at my fucking God.
God had to make
my fucking pepper.
Got My meatballs.
I know and I walk my fat on my feet,
spills over the outside of my sneakers.
I like that.
Look.
I like a little waterfall
going into my heel.
I stepped down,
just
rolls over.
I liked,
I liked the last one
cause my fucking gun,
my gun sticking out my legs
the way the back of my head.
Looks Dog,
the hot dog roll look.
Fat Sausages that have grown
out of the base of my skull,
it looks like it makes you
hungry for the fucking the
sausage
face.
You see a wrinkle in my face.
You see any spider marks by my eyes?
Fuck no,
because the flesh is pushing out
against the skin all the time.
It's pulled tight.
It makes me look young and vibrant.
Look at my Chin's fight.
All of them died.
I had a dude who told me that
that was William Shatner's.
Williamson has said this to him.
He said,
he goes,
wow.
He was interviewing them and we're
shocked apparently is like 80 years old.
And he goes,
you look great.
And he said,
well,
I realize that a certain year that
if I just put on five pounds a year,
I never get really wrinkly because
my face is like pushing fat out.
And he goes,
I'm serious.
Like apparently like he was a strategy
to like to stay young looking but keeping
your fake,
but I don't think you're supposed
to be that fat when you're 80.
I think that's like super bad for you.
Right?
That's just bullshit.
It
like because he's fat,
he's just made that shit.
Right.
He's working backwards.
But that is true.
If you will get older fat people,
they look way better than fat
joggers or the older joggers.
No.
I started running two years ago and I
lost weight in my face and now I look like
a fucking skull.
I take my hat.
I looked like a look at this.
When I take my hat off,
I looked like a light bulb.
There's no.
The light hits it and
they just look at it.
I just all my face and sunken and you
liked it better when you have like a
little plumpish I wasn't even plugged
but this is like a receipt and my Chin
looks like it's sticking out and I
don't know how to put weight on my face.
You know?
That's.
Once it's gone,
it's gone dancing.
I mean I'm telling you,
springsteen is,
is a fucking experience live.
I heard you two is but
a grateful dead concert.
I mean,
first of all,
you're tripping.
Every single person is dancing,
not bouncing back and forth.
Fucking are doing the backstroke and
looking at the sky like that is really
intense to be surrounded
by that for four hours.
So is that what it's all about?
Yeah.
It's this letting go into this energy.
Is it a.
is it a show that requires drugs?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
And is it a show that you don't understand
until you do it with drugs and then
you understand it 100 percent like you
ever the worst feeling in the world?
Do you ever go to a concert like pipe?
My wife me go to fucking
Dave Matthews band.
Oh God,
that's ugly.
And the wife made me go to is always bad.
But then when you say,
I shouldn't say the only thing worse
than Dave Matthews is John Meyer,
John Mica and John Mayer
Meyer and she was just like,
just enthralled by him.
Huh?
I could do.
John Mayer will know I can do to.
No,
I think he's great.
I think he's very talented.
But if your wife is really into going,
what I'm saying,
like she dragged you there
and just stares at him
and you're like,
I paid for this.
Paid to have your wife.
Close her eyes later.
Think about him.
You notice she's not clapping because
one of her hand slipped down or james
knuckle deep.
She's clapping with one hand.
It sounds like something stabbing a seal.
It sounds like one of those martial arts
movies where they rip the guy's heart
out after
she's just fist of herself.
She's all the way to your elbow.
Just gritting their teeth
and pounded it in there.
Get the wedding ring off.
She's just fucking strafing the.
You can see her rib cage
expand as a goes up there.
Fucking
okay,
let's go.
Then you realize it's in her asshole.
You thought it was bad?
It's all fucking shit up to her elbow.
What is this the fuck are you doing?
I thought we're going to see a concert.
Just says licking her arm.
Oh John.
Oh,
you make me my shit.
Meanwhile,
that's not the craziest
person that ever lived.
Nope.
That's not even close.
And you know,
what's amazing is every podcast,
no matter how long I ended up hanging out
with the guests for another 45 minutes
afterwards and you're like,
they don't want to leave here,
but I want to leave.
And it could have just kept going.
Well,
I do,
I do to a point.
I always feel like a lot of times
because I do the serious show first,
I've already given me an hour.
And then I usually
shoot a video with them.
I do this thing called
talk your way out of it,
where I give people and on
I'll do it to you right now.
I'm going to give you an
uncomfortable situation.
And then in a split second,
you're going to have to talk your way
out of it as if you're talking to the
person.
Okay?
All right.
Um,
are you go to the doctor's off and
he's gonna he's gonna check you out.
So,
um,
he bends you over the
table and then you go,
oh,
I forgot the rubber gloves.
He walks out.
You notice that the
medicine cabinets open,
you reach and you find
a bottle of Vicodin.
You see it as he's coming in,
he's going to bust you,
you take it,
you stick it up your ass to hide it.
The doctor spreads her cheeks.
He wants to look at.
You must look at your colon.
He puts his finger in.
He pulls out the bottle of Igon
and talk your way out of it.
Oh,
that's where that was
word
by word.
It's all you're in the clear.
Oh,
that's where it is.
Thanking them thinking maybe,
but no.
Usually it takes like two minutes.
People talk around it.
They described you average five words.
Just go right for C'mon man.
You can't.
You already busted wagner
and bottled up your ass.
You're a freak.
I did that.
I did that too.
Not that particular one.
I thought I was [inaudible] my last show
was with Natasha and I did that to her,
but it was in her pussy and she had
her feet in the stirrups and she goes,
oh,
I was just tightening that for you.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
But um,
So,
um,
fuck,
this is great.
This is great.
I just forgot we were talking about it.
It doesn't matter.